listen to the sounds of why hearing
matters to the Alaska Native people
hearing loss makes it hard to fish on
the open water hunt caribou and harvest
berries activities central to Alaskan
native culture hearing loss isn't unique
to rural Alaska its global the global
burden of disease project estimates that
there are 1.1 billion people living with
hearing loss worldwide that's more
people than the entire population here
in sub-saharan Africa over 80 percent
are in low and middle income countries
and many have no access to hearing care
the impact on people's lives is
tremendous Anouk is a three-year-old boy
I treated in Alaska ear infection
started when he was barely four months
old his parents brought him in to clinic
worried he didn't say much compared to
his brothers sure enough many rounds of
infections had resulted in hearing loss
without treatment a Noakes speech will
continue to lag behind he's more likely
to do worse in school have worse job
prospects and experience social
isolation but it doesn't have to be this
way the World Health Organization
estimates that half of all global
hearing loss can be prevented if annex
hearing loss is identified and treated
promptly his life and the opportunities
he has as he grows up could look vastly
different I'm an ear surgeon working
with partners around the world on new
pathways for hearing loss prevention
this solution comes from my
collaboration with a tribal health
organization called the Norton Sound
health Corporation hearing loss
evaluation traditionally requires
testing by an audiologist in a
soundproof room with a lot of
equipment an ear surgeon then examines
and milks ears under a microscope and
decides a treatment plan these resources
simply aren't available in remote
settings in a state where 75% of
communities aren't connected to a
hospital by Road an expensive flight is
required to overcome these barriers
Alaska has developed a state-of-the-art
telemedicine system that connects over
250 village health clinics with
specialists could triage all types of
health concerns my colleagues have
validated that you're related
telemedicine consult are equivalent to
an in-person exam in 2016
travel was prevented for 91% of patients
receiving specialty telemedicine in the
Norton Sound region telemedicine has
saved over 18 million and travel cost in
this single region over the past 15
years our team is taking the power of
telemedicine to a new level through a
project funded by the patient-centered
outcomes Research Institute for the
first time we are merging telemedicine
with mobile screening technology that
extends the reach of expert triage
beyond healthcare settings this
cell-based screen developed in South
Africa cost over 10 times less than
traditional equipment and does not
require advanced training if I were
screening a nook at school sound
attenuating headphones and noise
monitoring would take the place of a
sound booth and I would use a phone
adapter instead of a microscope to
examine his ears in a matter of minutes
screening and images are done we then
apply Alaska telemedicine technology to
transmit the data to specialists who
connect anouk to the treatment he needs
our team is launching a randomized trial
in 15 communities along the Bering Sea
to study how well this intervention
works our goal is to prevent childhood
hearing loss across the state of Alaska
but the concept is bigger than a single
state the impact is global
mobile telemedicine can revolutionize
access to care in Malawi for example
there are only two ear surgeons and 11
audiologists for a population of 17
million this technology could empower
teachers and community health workers to
provide access to care to children in
places like Malawi scaling up globally
could change children's lives who've
never had access to hearing care before
using just the power of a cell phone
it's time to change the course of
preventable hearing loss Anouk and
countless children like him are
depending on us thank you
[Applause]
[Music]